right I want to talk about it we
mentioned it in a while ago not when I
talk about it because we spoke about it
on an episode that we recorded and
they're no longer allowed to release
thanks Bella so let's talk about it now
women are spiteful they are why are
women so spiteful violent crazy as well
crazy and spiteful
and Eve they they ask for communication
but don't even know how to communicate
yeah fam yes right so crazy
spiteful and can't communicate let's
address firstly the spiteful ting so
what I mean by this is that let's say
we're in an argument run a little back
and forth we've got a little bit of a
disagreement
I haven't taken out the rubbish like I
said I would and you're angry I
understand that you're you're you're
angry so we get into a disagreement I
come up with an excuse I haven't taken
out rubbish because I'm so busy I've
been at work all day I'm tired my back
hose I don't want to take out the
rubbish and she comes back respectfully
yeah but I know but your job is to take
out the rubbish I do this and this and
this and you're supposed to take out the
rubbish and you ain't been doing it and
like well I understand that babe but no
offence if you want the rubbish taking
out that bad and I might hit breaking my
back to put food on the table go and
take out the [ __ ] rubbish get in it
then can we come back with why is your
back so sore which [ __ ] you've been
[ __ ] to make your back so sore
coz you sure as [ __ ] ain't been [ __ ]
me with your soft are small dick you
can't even [ __ ] your woman right and
you're talking about sore back spike
spike that's the definition that came
from the depth of us all she's planned
out
he's been waiting for the right moment
to chat [ __ ] about you bro you perv
this is what my mum was on about all
along when she told me not to get over
[ __ ] like you this is what she was
talking about just hurtful words for no
reason
but no reason guys will never say that
to a woman guys we'll keep it on topic
on topic on topic all the time like why
divert and talk about [ __ ] it doesn't
even matter when you know like you'll
just do it it's her thumb doing it to
hurt us and then when you bring it up
and say what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
why would you say [ __ ] I that it's got
nothing to do with this they'll come
back with why are you angry is true this
is my pet peeve yeah is my pet [ __ ]
thief so I have this argument or had
this argument with an ex all the time
she would say whatever the [ __ ] she
wants to say yeah irrelevant
hurtful spiteful and as soon as you say
why are you saying horrible [ __ ] back
that yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] what's wrong
with you she'll say how can you get
offended when it's true yeah why are you
mad it's true mmm big man listen to me
if it weren't true I wouldn't be
offended yeah because you're just making
sure I'm not gonna get offended by
random made-up [ __ ] yeah you said it
because you know it's true and you
wanted to hurt me
so I'm hurt because it's true don't ask
me why am i hurt when it's true I'm hurt
because it's true cuz if you were making
[ __ ] up guess what I ain't gonna get
hurt yeah cuz it's made up
[ __ ] easier property apiece we used
to do it like clockwork
yeah same ting arguing about a she
brings up B and then reverts to C and
then I would say but if it wasn't made
up if it was made up then I want to get
hurt and shield bring it back to a and
then we go from like clockwork every
[ __ ] argument my days or men
yeah fam that's why we're not together
like it was horrible [ __ ] hate it so
yes spiteful women why you [ __ ]
spiteful for so calculated calculates by
as well calculate they say low I'm sorry
I said this because I was angry this
like but you weren't though because when
you're angry you don't think about [ __ ]
yeah that's not happening now yeah when
I'm angry I think about what's going on
now yeah if I want to hurt you I need
information that's coming at me right
now yeah cuz I can't
I'm too angry to think about past years
yeah and what's going on I need to like
ICU and up like you're [ __ ] dry head
top family yeah like why is your why is
your gut hanging out like that what's
wrong with your [ __ ] nose like if I
need to hurt people I need if I'm in a
blind rage and I need it needs to be
here and now yeah so yeah when you're
bringing up [ __ ] from three months ago
that you didn't say that a mango you
calculated it and you've been sitting on
it waiting for the perfect opportunity
to just slice it like that women slide
it hurt me and we couldn't get on topic
in time enough for you so you for
[ __ ] I'm just putting in here yeah
let's wait till we get into a
disagreement I'm just gonna put in
[ __ ] arseholes soul calculated
it's horrible growth and they try and
say sorry like it's it's okay yeah and
then there's my feelings cuz you've hurt
my feelings you intentionally her
pension of you know say sorry cuz you
ain't sorry could you did it on purpose
yeah you tried to hurt my feelings and
you're not sorry because you're gonna do
it again at the time have you said why
you mad cuz it's true so you knew what
you were doing anyway say was
intentional love Amanda would never do
that to a woman never will never pull up
past experiences just to intentionally I
just say [ __ ] to [ __ ] hurt you just
to rattle your brain and we wouldn't do
that yeah bro and trust me if if you're
sitting there now if you're a woman and
you're sitting there now saying that's
[ __ ] my man does that all the time
your man doesn't love you he literally
doesn't because if I did it to someone
just to hurt their feelings
I trust me some I don't love you yeah
trust me I don't love you no I barely
like you probably I could just tolerate
you I can just tolerate yeah because if
I'm saying stuff cuz I want to hurt your
feelings it's because I don't like you
yeah facts if because I literally don't
like blacks that's the only reason he
says man like that men are like that
we are not like if I love you from I
don't want to hurt you facts I will not
say bad [ __ ] about you especially to
your face
brav is crazy it is [ __ ] crazy but
yeah um so that was spike communication
so women all the time they always want a
guy that can communicate bla bla bla and
women know it's true purely because of
the millions of memes I see all day
every day we ask you babes what's wrong
you black arm nothing babes what's wrong
I can clearly see something's wrong
because if I'm dating you I know you as
a woman I know and there's something
wrong I know when your Energy's off tell
me what's wrong say we could [ __ ]
resolve it and go to bed what is wrong
just tell me whether it's about me about
someone else just more time it's about
me anyway so just [ __ ] tell me what's
wrong say we can deal with it it's
definitely about it's definitely about
I've always if it was about [ __ ]
earth if it was about showering at work
she would have spilled the you would
have spilled it long if i milled the
beans so tell me what I've done so we
can resolve it so I can't say my tapas
and we can go to bed she'd be like like
I said babes nothing's wrong say no more
all right cool say no more I go and rest
my head I'm going to bed is way as next
day rolls around beef you know you're
not talking to me you've not made me
breakfast you've run out of all the hot
water
so am fix fam I'm vex so I'm a message
you out work when I'm at work you're at
work babes
how are you how's your day going over
fine Don I hate one word sent my one
word um replies with a full stop don't
stop me don't all stop me because I'll
bang you in your face it's not over it's
not because I stop it's not fine it's
not fine noise me annoys me white
why do you always want to go to
communicate but you can't open your
[ __ ] mouth to tell me what's wrong
but if you don't know what's wrong then
what's the [ __ ] point in talking
about it what does that even mean cuz I
wouldn't be asking you what's wrong if I
knew what was wrong if I knew what was
wrong why would I ask you what's wrong
we're not mind reader's
yeah woman we're not mind reader's fan I
feel like they think we're mine
Peters I live with Miguel so I know you
man are crazy I know you man knock free
I'm looking at you cos I know you man
are crazy so don't tell me I don't know
what I'm talking about you're all
collapse all of your crap just say yeah
just tell me what's wrong just
communicate it's not hard you guys make
it seem like it's the biggest obstacle
in the world to just talk and express
yourself because more time we are
logical enough to understand how you
feel
empathize with that and try and make it
work because like James said if we love
you we will talk we can make we're gonna
sort it because I'm not trying to make
you feel bad and vice-versa you're not
trying to make me feel bad so the sooner
we resolve this the sooner you can make
me breakfast cuz I'm rough the sooner we
can get back I ain't trying to go bed
mad oh I hate that I hate that go into
bed mad firm nah wanna go bed mad let's
sort it the [ __ ] out without if I ask
you what's wrong I need to know what's
wrong
fam and like oh brother it's just so
annoying if I'm just like just [ __ ]
say it man the [ __ ] up and see what's
wrong with you in it mmm and none of
this well if you don't know then I can't
help you there's no point talking about
it all right but two can play that game
if that's what you want to do cuz we'll
fight today we will today we'll swipe to
them because you're gonna I'm gonna
anoint you now cuz everything I do is
gonna annoy you and you're gonna push my
buttons firm and I'm gonna bang your
head against these times this is the
fing as well this is the thing I might
know what's wrong in terms of a
situation I might know you're pissed off
about this specific situation but I'm
seeing it like how can i how can I
[ __ ] explain it if I'm sat over here
the cameras to my left if I'm sat over
there the cameras to my right we're both
looking at the same [ __ ] camera BAM
but to me is left unto us right
different angles disobey playing fam I
can't see from over there yeah I can't
see how you can possibly tell me it's
right because I'm looking in from left
yeah I can't you need to explain it to
you from yeah yes I know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
know why you're pissed off yeah explain
so explain so I can understand and then
ruff we could move on we can snuggle and
[ __ ] and sleep women they just it gets
me he greatly they just get me [ __ ]
he'd just communicate it's not that hard
as much as you want the guy to
communicate you need to opium up and
tell us what's wrong these times that's
why they getting spiteful yeah they're
not communicating it when is vexing
embryo and they want to leave it yeah
and then next time when we're in a
different argument that's when you want
to bring it oh yeah yeah and I'm like
what are you even coming from where is
this coming from
DM yeah talkin about boy BM Shanice from
from from what whose work no nope ah
yeah if I'm [ __ ] dead it's just so
annoyed exhausting like I don't have
energy for this less like let's get
through our day expending as least
energy as possible yeah bad energy bad
energy let's just all be happy it's like
sometimes I I've been in relationships
before and then you go through this back
and forth back and forth back and forth
and you're just like brought do you want
to be with me yeah do you wanna be with
ya because these times you it's like you
want to be angry you want to sit on it
you want to sit and be angry at ya
and it's like I don't want to be angry
at anyone yeah especially the person
that I'm trying to be with I'm trying to
be with like I wanna be with you cuz you
make me happy yeah if you just keep
making me sad
big man I don't want to be here yeah
just like when I'm sat at work and my
[ __ ] boss is in my ear and the works
piling up and I'm stressed and I'm going
into work every day like fam I hate you
here guess what firm man's on indeed I'm
looking for a new team I don't want to
be here anymore
and that's exactly what I'll do to you I
don't want to be here anymore
just higher making me sad I would be
LinkedIn I would jump on LinkedIn and
I'll find my happy place bro it's crazy
and it's like um Jacob said it best he
said it a couple years ago and it has
stuck to me so much throughout the years
it literally changed my perspective on
everything yeah and it's like a
relationship is like a friendship
so the only difference if I have a
girlfriend the only difference between
me and my girlfriend and me and you is
that I [ __ ] em hmm
like that's pretty much the only
difference I see a funny meme I'm
sending it to you of sending it to her
like you for something like if something
interesting happens in my life I'm
telling her I'm telling you yeah like we
like [ __ ] out even mean you sleep in
the same bed sometimes like like
everything is the same we eat together
we sleep together we laugh together
required to give her like everything I
do with her
is exactly the same way I'll do it to
you yeah the only difference is is me
and her have sex yeah so based on that
difference if me and you started arguing
non-stop I guess we're not boys yeah and
I don't need to have a sit-down and say
who had this ain't working yeah I'm just
gonna slowly tune you out yeah we don't
need to have a conversation by it
because turns up in oh boy we just we
just don't get along yeah and it we
probably won't even have any resentments
about it because it just turns out we've
got different values in life and it's
happened a million times there's a
million boys that I used to have I don't
talk to you anymore
um that's fine this life it's just life
yeah I'll get new friends because me and
you are friends because we keep fighting
that's just a red flag with clearly not
boys yeah but for some reason because
I'm having sex with this one hmm they
think that we can argue every other day
and it's all good yeah like nothing's
gonna change yes we argue all the time
but that's just what people do when
they're in a relationship
oh na ji na na ji I've known if you had
for 11 years and I think we've argued
one god I think we've argued one so I
can tell you
brav we ain't supposed to walk you every
day trust me trust Oh
and we used to live together yes so
exactly the same thing I saw you every
single day 24 hours a day I was there
and we argued once yeah so big man
because we're sleeping together I'm
supposed to argue all the time
nah you don't want to be with me you
don't love me and you don't want to be
if you don't want to see me happy
because all I want to do is see you
happy yeah I want to see you thrive you
don't want the same that's the
difference between boys friendships and
girls friendships as well I was talking
to one of my boys on literally just
before the clock struck 12 on New Year's
New Year's Eve - New Year's Day he sent
me a DM they sent me a voice no and it
resonated with me because he said he
says stuff like a bond between men is
hard to break like there's always gonna
be a bond between like a boy and a girl
when they gonna go by but bond between
two men it's so hard to break and he
used like an example of the fact that
yes we don't talk every day yes we don't
have to message over every day yes they
don't have to check up in each other
every day but when we do speak or when
we do meet up it's always gonna be love
con with this boy as well you may my be
you know oh yeah I've known Ivy for
we're mean in 2012 I know it's a 2007 no
went to hunt 2006-2007
so that's 13 years of my life that's
almost hot my heart my life yeah yeah
and we've never had an argument like
never had an argument and that's purely
because I know who he is as a person he
knows who I am as a person
he knows the valleys I've got and vice
versa you know I mean I'm lyin I would
never put him in a situation where I
know he's gonna get pissed off so he's
gonna argue with me but girls will more
likely do something snaky and shady to
their other girls that he claimed that
they're best friends or whatever girls
have more arguments like girlfriends
have more arguments then guy friends
because guys don't argue because girls
put stupid emotion into it where guys
think logically and girls would do some
dumb [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] or argue about dumb
things that don't even matter like some
of the things like Bella has told me
about like her other friends and Retta
it's like why even why is this even a
discussion hmm like is she your girl
she's not your girl do you not I mean
why why is this a discussion
it's just some of the things you guys
talk about or argue about or beef about
it's so miniscule it blows my mind
why do you expend so much energy
chatting [ __ ] but that's the thing
is well it it actually hits perfectly
what you just said about you would never
put him in a situation that you know is
gonna piss him off and he would never
put you in a situation because like
prime example for example like Luis mmm
Luis is on a vegan tip at the minute
okay he wants to be vegan okay obviously
from the episode I did like I did the a
couple episodes ago we all know I feel a
certain way about vegans yeah
but because he's my boy he knows not to
say certain [ __ ] to me that's gonna
trigger me and I know not to belittle
his choices and start bringing up [ __ ]
that will trigger him and we coexist
fine fact and we can actually have a
conversation about his choice to be
vegan without me being like [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] this is this and he knows
to have a conversation with me about
vegan and and not say random stupid
facts that don't make sense that he
knows that I've gotta piss me off and we
can have an appropriate conversation and
we're all blessed and then even after
that happens it's not fake interaction
like a lobby woman will if they're
pissed off about something or if
something riles them up they'll have a
fake interaction and then they'll go to
the hair corner she'll go to her corner
and then it's just yeah yeah there's
none of that I ain't gonna then have a
conversation with him
run back to you and because guys aren't
like that I'm not like that I don't hold
resume is like that if I've got
something to say to you from office say
yeah I'll say you must have pissed me
off to even put me in that position
so I'm gonna [ __ ] today yeah and that's
the reason why boys get along more than
girls and that's the reason why I feel
like male friends stay closer than
female friends as I said as a like a
man-to-man friendship that bond is so
hard to break bro so hard to break if
you've got a good boy you'll be boys for
life literally forever literally forever
family because I don't know I don't know
that many goes correct me if I'm wrong
but I don't need that many girls
ago another girl for so long and not had
like a major fall out bro I mean yeah
still claim yes friend yeah you've been
having fallouts
yeah bin and I know specific examples of
my head which I won't say office because
it doesn't concern me by no specific
examples in my head and I know
specifically were like this is so this
is so true because these are people I've
known for a long time in my life mhm and
I've known about their experiences with
their best friends and for a fact
they've had argues with a best friends
they've had so many disconnection beulah
and they've not spoken for months or
weeks or big man I've never not spoken
to you every single week of my life
hundred percent since the day I met you
the day I met you I spoke to you every
single week of my life hundred percent
if we go three days of our speaking I'm
like well I'm
where are you alive fax or scan on facts
because we're boys fam that's just how
it is girls you man are nuts proof
that's all it is too much emotion I
don't know why it is I don't know what
you've it's hard to explain man it is
hard to explain like I don't feel like
they'd understand the point I'm trying
yeah it's like it's like what we were
talking about on the podcast yesterday
we're not putting out like women we'll
try and explain and justify things that
they've done in an emotional state yeah
like they find it difficult to own it
yeah and say this is boy I was emotional
and this is why I did it
and sometimes they all say yeah I was
hormonal and say sorry so for that but
like if they've done something and they
know they've done it in an emotional
statement they'll say like yeah but this
happened and this happened this happened
this happened this how about this
happened this happened like and I think
like a true analogy to explain like
emotion versus logic is I was actually
listening to a podcast about it like the
other day and it kind of works in both
ways so I say sit save like life at the
end of the day is cutthroat so you can't
you can't use a motion to get you
anywhere I like to compare business and
relationships because it actually works
like side by side in a lot ways that
people don't think about
so in when it comes to personal
relationships like you just said like
especially women will have a situation
that have an emotional outburst
and then when [ __ ] hits the fan and [ __ ]
has turned negative because of the
emotional thing they did they'll say oh
but she said this and he did this and
just happened this and this happened
this and this happened this and they
won't own the fact of like brav you know
what regardless of all this external
[ __ ] that's going on I had an emotional
outburst and I [ __ ] up
they won't own it and people are
expected to even like accommodate that
yeah like women expect you to if they've
had an emotional outburst they expect
you to accommodate yeah because they've
given you justification for their
emotions they expect you to accommodate
that and be cool with that and move on
when we're like no that's not how real
life works and the reason I compared to
business is because let's say you're at
work you're getting riled up like
clients are pissing you off this is
happening
you haven't you didn't get any sleep the
night before you're [ __ ] hungry like
you're getting in like you're getting
into an emotional state and then your
boss comes over says something that
pisses you off even more and then you're
like you know what brav [ __ ] you like
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
prick don't [ __ ] speak to me again
you stupid ugly [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah guess
what brother you're sad you're fired
you're sacked BAM nothing you can do you
can throw all the justifications in the
world
I didn't sleep I'm hungry this has
happened in my life my mom's in hospital
this is a guess what fam you're still
sad yeah and you wouldn't even try and
justify it because you know you're just
sacked and that's why you won't
that's why no one does that to their
boss yeah no one even contemplates
man-woman doesn't matter no one even
contemplates doing that because they
know the consequences yeah but because
we're at home now yeah you think it's
calm you think you can say and do what
you want in an emotional state yeah and
explain the reasons why you're emotional
and guess what we're at Ground Zero now
and we're fine we're back to this and
I'm supposed to accept that yeah is that
no no no no no no no it doesn't work
like that it's crazy it literally
doesn't work like that
and I it baffles me the way that even
though like I say women I know God there
are guys that do it as well but in my
experience if it's men and women that do
that it's like you know you
do that work you know when you get that
annoying thing when you're at school
yeah and say you wouldn't do it at home
so I don't know why you're doing it here
I used to [ __ ] hate when teachers say
that yeah but it is actually true it is
actually true because you can say no you
wouldn't act like this at work you
wouldn't act like this in certain
situation so why do you feel it's okay
to act like you're out of control I was
it why is it okay to to pretend like say
you didn't have a choice like your
emotions bubbled up so much that you had
to say this you had to do this you had
to disrespect this person you had to do
this you you you you expect people to
understand your actions in an emotional
state and use logic to explain away your
emotions when you know there are
situations in your life where you would
have been able to control him
but for some reason with me you can't
you can't yeah like it's such [ __ ]
[ __ ] from only you [ __ ] slag own
it and say I did it because I wanted to
do yeah cuz I hate you and I don't want
to be with you and I said cuz I wanted
to say it perfect example what we talk
to be spoken by a few episodes good the
Kevin Hart situation on the plane oh so
obvious for reference if you haven't
seen the episode he got into a argument
with his personal trainer going back and
forth and Kevin was saying some hurtful
[ __ ] like if you if all of this stop
today like of all of Kevin Hart's family
ever stop right now he said to his
trainer where would you be would you be
around do you have oh he asked him do
you have a home multiple times and he
was round up with emotion and stuff
granted but literally the episode after
he sent a mass text to like his group
shaft guys and owned it Oh apologize
none of this this is going on in my life
this is going on in my life this has
happened in my life I am sorry but you
should have said this and know that I'm
said I take full responsibility
simple straightforward they never come
with like a backhanded apology I'm sorry
I said this but you should no no no no
nice like if you've done something
[ __ ] up and wrong own it and just
regardless of what was going on yeah I
[ __ ] up I should have done that birth
and I'm sorry and I ain't gonna do it
again yeah boy yeah but these hoes film
these photos will say what I want I say
do whatever one is and I feel like they
do that because they feel like they
Lynette which nine times out of ten
they're right there's never gonna be a
repercussion anyway it's true and that's
the reason why they do it cuz it's like
a gouge your free card they can say well
they want to do anyone because they know
that's not gonna be a repercussion and
nine times out of ten one more time
10/10 don't ever risk repercussion but I
feel like that's the thing though man
because I this kind of really bores down
we're getting deep on this one hmm
it really boils down to kind of what do
you see as a relationship they say
that's that's what do you think yeah
like what do you think a relationship is
like do you think a relationship is just
where you're you're with someone and you
like you said you can say and do what
you want to that person without any
repercussion because there's certain
kind of socially constructed do's and
don'ts like can you put hands on your
partner no can you cheat on your partner
no other bums for the shell can't it's
not coming to my head right but like
yeah like can you be abusive to your
partner no so as long as it doesn't tick
any of those lists yeah you do you do
what you want and you expect your
partner to forgive you and get over it
yeah and it's like no no fam no because
if we were boys I've actually said it to
like probably my last three girlfriends
when push has come to shove and I'm like
I don't want to be here anymore
like I've literally said what I said
Jacob said is like fam if we were boys
right now I wouldn't be your friend
anymore so why the [ __ ] am I supposed to
stay and be your your your partner yeah
like why give me a reason why because
you talk to me like [ __ ] you treat me
like [ __ ] and you think because you're
not cheating on me
hit me whatever I'm supposed to be like
taken yes fine so there's like what but
if you're in it like if you're listening
to this and you're in a situation and
hopefully you can own up to yourself and
say [ __ ] I do that if you're in a
situation when you're in a relationship
with someone and you think it's okay as
long as you don't tick box a B or C as
long as you avoid that great let not the
gray oh that dark area of do not do this
if you're in a relationship with someone
like do you think it's
okay to act like that and do what you
want or are you in a relationship
because you want that person to be happy
all the time cause like when I'm in a
relationship someone I want that person
to be happy all the time
and that's not me saying I will bend
over backwards 24 hours a day to make
sure they're happy yeah I don't want to
be the owner of their happiness I just
whatever they're do want to grow with
them and run or we're both whatever
you're doing in your day at any point I
just want you to be happy yeah that's
the let's literally all I want hours of
relationship yeah I want you to make me
happy I want to make you happy
foundation yeah I want us to have our
own separate lives and have our own
sources of external happiness but again
I'm not out here to take what's going on
at work in my family all these other
stuff bring that home to you and just
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang beat
the [ __ ] out of you verbally say okay
I'm done
forgive me you say okay and then we
start again yeah
it's this is crazy fam it's crazy
because I I feel like when you see so
many people now and you asked you like
you asked them like or has the missus
and it's just like something yeah drain
him and so I know we I've got boys now
so how's the missus are just uh this and
that and then you like bro [ __ ] that
yeah leave and they're like come on you
know like women being women and like
we've been together five six seven years
now like this is how it's supposed to be
at this point and stuff it's like fam
guess what no it's literally not I don't
know who told you that yeah and I don't
know yeah I don't know who you think
decides what's okay for your life yeah
but like if I'm asking you how is this
person and your I get out please please
please please is crazy fam so it's like
yeah like I said if you're listening
you're in a relationship and you're not
actively just wanting your partner to be
happy all the time
then fam what's going on what is going
on you get you clearly need to
communicate it's true because the thing
is as well and you know what I actually
this actually ties in with it
um I feel like I'm taking over this
poker so I'm sorry from Mon I'm random
Raven
it's like I've said it to you before
it's like women and men like obviously
there's there's exceptions there's
always exceptions but you were always
like here a lot of the time men like men
will rarely say like I need to get
myself a girlfriend and they like
they've got no image of their head of
who they want they never just sit there
and block I need a girlfriend man like I
need to find a girlfriend
they don't say stuff like then they're
happy being alone for the most part and
then they will meet someone we've both
done it we've met someone doesn't work
met someone doesn't work met someone
doesn't work my summer doesn't work and
we're not seeking anything we're not
looking for anything we're just meeting
new people and then you meet someone
bang clicks clicks you don't even have
to say this is the one you just like you
just know and you're like all right I
actually want to spend more time with
this person yeah so now that you've
developed that bond with that person
it's like I only want the best for you
all the time like I care about this
person like you make me happy I hope I
make you happy let's be happy and
relaxed unless not beef yeah whereas a
lot of time you'll hear women I need a
man i need a man I've been single for
six months from I need a man perfect and
like yeah they're like then they're like
jumping on tinder jumping on this
jumping on that and they're like does he
take this box does he take this box nope
does he take this box easy and they're
like can I see myself with you can I see
myself with you can I see myself with
you would I want you around my kids
would I want to bring you to my mom nope
nope nope nope nope and then there's
they'll meet John and John what I want
Don to meet my mom yeah do I think John
will be okay around my kids yeah
it's John good-looking yeah is this dick
good yeah
like does he have a good job yeah all
right all right let me pursue a
relationship with John here and it's
like do you even like John Fran that
should have been the first thing do you
like John do you want John to be happy
yeah and it's like they skip past that
thing and that's why two years down the
line [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] the rubbish [ __ ] your dick [ __ ]
this year your mum's are pretty
this this this is your job ain't [ __ ]
you ain't [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then they're like I don't
want to be single yeah
so John forgive me I'll suck you off
forgive me I was emotional I had an
outburst less like there's a lot [ __ ]
going on with this and that and I work
too pissing me off like I got
overwhelmed and I took it out you I'm
sorry and then it will happen again and
again and again all because day one fam
do you like John do you care about
John's happiness yes no genuinely and
it's like family it's like they skip
that point because they were more
concerned about finding themself a man
that ticks XY and said you're funny you
say that because there's chick that used
to see I don't see anymore
you know who is so you talk now it's
just like friends or whatever and then
she keeps telling me ah
I need to find myself a husband and I'm
thinking big man you're 22 mm you're 20
[ __ ] to like why do you need to find
a hut like live your [ __ ] life babes
and I've told her that several times
you live your life it it will happen
when it happens why you rush it I get
the biological clock aspect but why the
[ __ ] are you Russian do you know I mean
Reich's 22 Angela and needs why do you
need to find a husband why why firm why
like his currency like that's like music
like me saying I need money I need money
because I need to do this this and this
I can tell you why I need money I need a
husband why they got an answer because
I'm the only one of my girls that hasn't
got one that's the I hate I hate you
love that because they love to compare
bro I hate [ __ ] like that
prov more time if four guys if I see my
boys happy and relationship I'm just
happy for them not oh my god I need a
girlfriend firm I'm just happy for you
cuz right what if if and when I find
mine gas job hundred percent of girls
flip you like all my girls have got
girlfriends I'm so bored I wish I had a
man
yeah you know this we have to do that
with big man it's not you are 21 22 23
max brother prime example prime example
of that is like like my brother
so my brother first of all my brother
loves being in a [ __ ] relationship
and it's annoyed me to no end in my life
but I've accepted it
and he is few years and I'm happy when
he's happy so whatever but prime example
the relationship that he was in as of
late duh-duh go in my opinion she was
actually lovely so just in case he
listens to this she was actually lovely
she was nice she was super polite she
was funny and like yeah she was a nice
person but she would invite my man to
[ __ ] everything anything that was
going on he was invited to the house
multiple times a week for have dinner
with her family
any time her go or her friends were
going out for drinks he was invited any
time and her girls would invite their
boyfriends and then any time any
basically any social situation that she
had going on her life my a man's invited
he's coming and the some of them what it
got to a point and then she invited him
to basically she was having like she was
going to a party right it was a surprise
pie for her friend her friend had just
graduated and she was like how do you
want to come to this surprise pie for my
friend's graduation yeah my brother's
like yeah cool man
he said he rocked up there and the only
people at this pie was the girl whose
buyer was her parents my brother's
girlfriend who was on the girls course
another girl who was on the girls course
and like one more of the girl's best
friends so it was a tight I need party
fam hi it wasn't a pie if I was a little
gathering to celebrate this girl's
graduation and my man was like why am I
here but why did you invite
and it was like in my opinion when she
found my brother
she definitely just wanted a man yeah
not to say that my mother's not a good
catch because he [ __ ] is but like she
definitely definitely just wanted a man
like she wanted a man and like
throughout the relationship is started
to break down I'm sure he won't mind me
saying this but he's had to put down
because he was given like he had deep
fitness for her and he was given like
he'd always get gifts and he was
thoughtful and wanting to want to want
to do this and in the end like kindness
she was a bit more like I'm not like I'm
not given enough it's you like I'm not
given enough to you to to like I feel
bad that you're giving me so much yeah
you're doing so much for me and you're
giving me so much and I'm not
reciprocating enough and I don't have
the inner urge to reciprocate enough
yeah so I don't think we should continue
this relationship because you all give
her and I'm not yeah and I feel like the
person that I should be with I should
want to do want to do all these things
right yeah so that was a justification
from the breaking up so it's like you
wanted like you got what you got stuff
man
you dragged him to end everything you
had going on yeah but yet you didn't
have the urge to give him anything back
you just wanted a man you just wanted a
man so when you met him again you
skipped the first tick do I like him
care about this person and he went
straight to he's funny he's good-looking
he's got a nice car he's got a nice job
his family seems nice
bang-bang go on love him straight and
I'm pretty sure their first or second
day was like a social ting like I said
even get to know him as a human being mm
it's just like a showboat a showboat
things my guy now dragged him around to
every little social situation and then
we started getting serious between them
she was like its she's woken up now
she's uh wow I actually don't want this
relationship
this isn't ratio part one and she might
not admit to herself but clearly you
just wanted someone to direct because
your friends had man yeah you were tired
of going to dinner and everyone's got
their man and UN and now you needed to
find yourself a man and it's just like
I company faxes yeah cuz you're better
off staying single and embracing the
fact that you're singing and working on
yourself and just being happy by
yourself then force in and yeah Manish
and yet we think is a slight connection
win weightless when they're single as
well it's like it's like a whole triumph
thing like a whole when they're instead
of being happy like you can tell you're
not truly happy about being single
because there's a whole like [ __ ] men
don't want to talk to anyone I ain't
talking to this person I'm talking to
that person don't message me like I'm
done with men I just want to be by
myself want to focus on myself and it's
such like a statement like when you come
to the social situations you know and
you ain't got a man like it's like you
need to let everyone I don't need a man
I don't need a man under you're so
against it's never just a placid like
I'm just saying I'm just single because
I'm single from like that's it it's
always a either one extreme to the other
it's a statement or is like this is my
man yeah this is my man we do this this
and this we're gonna get married in two
and a half years we're gonna have two
girls and a boy
I guess such a thing is a con I
literally can't I don't understand it
we're definitely never gonna get to the
bottom of it but that was nice to just
express it my longest e-wrap cool man I
got deep in that it did I like that one
I like that one